[Music]
hi and welcome to serverless migration
station I'm Wesley from Google joined by
serverless Expedition host Martin to
help you modernize your apps running on
Google cloud in this and the next
migration module our little friend
portal will take you on a journey to
migrate from App engine's users API or
bundle service to the cloud identity
platform and I am happy to be here as
always West so uh what's today's
migration about well the app engine user
service provides a lightweight and easy
to use Google sign-in service meaning
use authentication backed by Google as
the identity provider however to make
your app engine apps more portable we
recommend moving away from App engine
only services like the users API that
said this video won't feature any
migrating at all no migrating at all
always uh why not I thought this was the
migration video series
you're right USA Porter does take users
from point A to point B but here in
module 20 we need to take a detour first
to reacquaint folks with app engine
users We'll add its use to the module 1
sample app and then we can migrate to
Identity platform in module 21. okay I
think I get it uh we're taking one of
our original python 2 apps adding the
app engine user service to it and then
we migrate that app from the old user
service to the new identity platform you
got it Martin in module one we have
already migrated from App engine's web
app 2 framework to flask a popular
framework in the python Community while
web app 2 apps run on app engine flask
apps run on app engine and most other
hosting services so you can move off of
app engine if you ever need to pause now
to review the module 1 video and its
codelab to reacquaint yourself with that
migration because this module picks up
from where that one leaves off great
before we move ahead earlier you said
users was a lightweight Google sign-in
service for app engine does the user
service do anything more than sign in
and sign out ah good question Martin yep
aside from logging in and out the user
service helps your app determine whether
a user has signed in and if so gives
your app basic user information it also
provides convenient login and logout
links for your app as well as supporting
the concept of admin users and admin
only functionality ah great overview of
the user service now how are we going to
use it in our sample app here
another good question since the goal of
this is the Porto identity platform
we're not going to make any major
updates and keeping it simple the app's
core functionality stays identical all
we're doing is adding a login or logout
button at the top showing the user's
email if signed in and also an admin
badge if the user is an admin sounds
good I asked our co-workers how it often
says keep it as simple as possible by
the way who or what determines if a user
is an admin inside our app engine app
you make a user an admin of the app by
granting them the app engine app admin
IAM role but what if I'm a developer
working on the app and I need to be able
to deploy new versions of it uh how is
that kind of admin different from this
kind of app admin you mentioned
yeah it's very different people who use
the app are different from those who are
developing the app for app developers
roles like viewer editor and owner are
appropriate however they are Legacy
roles that come with too many
permissions so we generally recommend
avoiding them bottom line is you're an
admin if you belong to at least one of
the four roles you see on screen but in
keeping with the best practice of least
privilege the app engine app admin role
is the best and most restrictive role to
have yet still be recognized as an admin
user Ah that's great I'm a lot less
confused now Wes about these two
different types of admin I'm ready to
add the user service to the module 1 app
can I do it by hand while you're showing
us on screen
absolutely grab your module 1 python 2
app if you did the code lab or clone the
repo or download the zip file if you
didn't pause here if you need to do that
module 1 is where we'll start you'll
find the links down below to the repo
and module 20 codelab to do this by hand
with me now or on your own time all
right let's go to the computer now and
do this
for all migrations we really want to
start with a working app in this case
the module 1 sample whether you use your
code from doing the code lab or copied
it from the repo delete the lib folder
if you have one and run the PIP install
command to install or reinstall the
third-party libraries into the lib
folder upgrading to Python 3 is great
because you no longer have to do this
vendoring or self-bundling now run
gcloud app deploy to upload to the cloud
the app should show the most recent
visits including the visit you just made
now that we've verified that it works
let's add login logout and admin
functionality using the user's API in
many migrations we start by modifying
the configuration files but not this
time none of the config files need to be
touched so let's go straight to the core
application file main.py first add an
import of the user's API the module
Google app engine API users that was
pretty straightforward the most critical
update is to add support for users and
admins in the main Handler the key
changes are reflected directly in the
user interface or UI so we need to add
all of the Necessities to the context
for the web web template and the context
differs depending on whether the user is
logged in or not the first thing we do
in the new section of code is to get the
current user if false the user isn't
logged in so set the context to
generically show user as a username
display a login button with an action of
being sent to a login page of clicked
and if user object comes back instead
this means the user is logged in so set
the context with the user's email
address and switch the login button to
logout next check if the user is an
admin or not and show an admin badge if
they are
signing out is a little bit more
convoluted than it should be
unfortunately the user's API create
logout URL function returns a link that
allows you out of all of your Google
accounts out of all your browser tabs
which is probably not what you want so
our version handcrafts a URL that logs
users out of the app only and redirects
back to home where home comes from the
flask request objects environment
variables finally the most recent visits
are added to the context regardless of
whether the user is logged in or not and
the template is rendered now that's it
for the main application updates now
let's take a look at the index.html web
template most of it stays the same but
we slip in what's required to support
user logins at the top display a welcome
message with the user's email if logged
in or just user if not this is the who
variable an admin badge in monofont is
displayed if the user is an admin Yep
this is the admin variable the log
button variable is the placeholder for
the login or logout button if the user
is signed in it's a logout button if
they're not it's a login button that's
the job of the sign variable a
horizontal line divides this user
information and functionality from the
most recent visits display which remains
unchanged the second new chunk of code
added to the web template is at the
bottom it gets the log button and sets
The Click action to either the login or
logout urls
if the button says login then the link
variable is the login link and similarly
for logout those are all the changes to
add use of the user service to the
module 1 sample app now let's deploy
this new model 20 app to confirm it
works before that replace the lib folder
by deleting the old one and running the
PIP install command to reinstall the
third-party dependencies now run gcloud
app deploy to deploy the app
once it's uploaded you should now see
welcome user with a login button at the
top followed by the expected most recent
visits now click it and log in as
yourself if you're the only Google user
you'll be prompted for the normal
username and password if you're signed
in with multiple Google accounts then
you'll see the account selector first
and be prompted with a password if
necessary after that once you sign in as
an owner of the app you should see the
admin badge applied right next to your
email address click the log up button
and you should be returned to the
original welcome user followed by a
login button now login as another Google
user who isn't an admin you should see
the email address but no admin batch
followed by another logout button so
that was a rundown of our modification
to the module one app resulting in the
module 20 app integrated with the app
engine user service okay time to wrap up
thanks for the tutorial Wes uh can you
point us to the users API docs so our
viewers can learn more about it
sure Martin below I've got all kinds of
links to the users API overview page the
API reference docs and all of the iaam
roles because they can be confusing
which includes the four rules I
mentioned earlier that gives users admin
access that's a lot of links I'll take a
look now that we've added user sign-in
to our sample app uh what are our next
steps
while next in module 21 we're going to
show you how to migrate to the identity
platform but before we do that a quick
note that in Fall of 2021 the app engine
team made bundle services like users
available in second generation runtimes
like python3 so you don't have to move
off of users in order to upgrade your
app more on this is covered in module 17
but if you do want to migrate to
Identity platform check out the identity
platform docs as well as the cloud
resource manager API which we need to
use you can also do the module 21 code
lab to get a head start or check out the
module 21 code samples in the repo and
of course the video I heard that
identity platform is based on Firebase
authentication which is a client-side
solution so it's perfect for those using
modern web Frameworks like View and
angular and react is that right
yep it is based on Firebase auth which
also allows users to log in from Twitter
and Facebook and a bunch of other
identity providers and also yes that
users is strictly server-side solution
so in module 21 we'll be converting it
to client side and we look forward to
having you join us for that migration
this is Wesley on behalf of Martin and
Porter and we'll see you at that next
migration station or on another
serverless Expedition soon happy travels
please
[Music]